el mundo está completamente demente si
la gran mayoría de personas que vivimos
en este mundo estamos completamente
dementes vivimos en la demencia total y
lo peor de todo esto es que ni siquiera
nos damos cuenta el daño que nos hace y
aún así seguimos estando aquí muchos de
nosotros tenemos sueños deseos
aspiraciones metas sobre todo metas pero
qué actividades llevamos a cabo en
concreto para poder realizar nuestras
metas la definición que más me gusta de
la demencia es la siguiente hacer
exactamente lo mismo todos los días y
aún así esperar obtener un resultado
diferente
me permito este ejemplo porque siento
que estoy en frente de emprendedores es
como si quisieran quedarse en su sillón
todos los días esperando que las cosas
cambiarán y al día siguiente hacer lo
mismo y otra vez lo mismo y otra vez lo
mismo perdón pero si lo hacen están
completamente dementes
si está mal estar demente no
es imposible quitarnos de esta demencia
tampoco es difícil sí claro que sí y
creo que por eso estamos aquí en los
siguientes 10 minutos o 15 minutos te
voy a dar 5 consejos 5 consejos para los
cuales puedas empezar para salir de este
terrible bache pero sobre todo para
poderte contestar esta pregunta número 1
consejo número 1 es siempre real si te
prometo que si eres lo suficientemente
bueno y le echas ganas obviamente vas a
poder engañar a todo el mundo
absolutamente todos menos a la persona
más importante a ti mismo ahorita
probablemente estás diciendo que sí que
tú te has engañado una y varias veces y
está bien
cuánto tiempo más crees que te sirva en
serio cuánto tiempo más crees que te
sirva 5 10 15 20 30 50 años también te
lo compro pero te voy a dar un consejo
más no pierdas tiempo porque eso es lo
único que no regresa el tiempo no va a
regresar nunca mi etapa como emprendedor
social empezó más o menos cuando yo
tenía unos 8 años de edad yo no lo veía
de esa manera me gustaba mucho lo que
hacía pero no lo veía de esa manera y
llegó el tiempo en donde tienes que
empezar a trabajar donde empiezan esas
presiones sociales y empecé a trabajar
cuando tenía como unos 15 años y lo hice
no lo hacía mal tampoco un genio pero lo
hice
pero no me sentía yo
y paso el tiempo seguía engañando me
seguir viviendo en la demencia hasta que
hace diez meses dije no ya no puedo más
estoy cansado de hacer las cosas que la
gente cree que son mejores para mí y me
voy a empezar a enfocar en las cosas que
yo sé que quiero hacer wow
wow a partir de ese momento todos esos
terribles trabajos que tenía que hacer
se convirtieron en las experiencias más
padres de toda mi vida a partir de ese
momento todo lo que yo pensaba que eran
sacrificios insignificantes se volvieron
en gran parte de mi felicidad te voy a
decir una cosa sé completamente real vas
a tener tres cosas vas a ser mucho más
eficiente vas a tener una gran ventaja
sobre los demás y vas a ser más feliz
hasta el favor y sé completamente real
número dos existe un gran camino corto
si cuando empecé a hacer esto les
prometo que me senté escribirlo y tenía
unas ganas de darles la receta secreta
decirles que caminamos por un lado por
el otro abría una puerta y ahí va a
estar tu objetivo
pero no es así así que lamento que hayas
tenido que llegar hasta aquí para
escuchar lo siguiente el camino corto se
divide en dos y el primero de ellos se
llama conocimiento como un gran sabio
decía si no haces más de lo que ya sabes
hacer no vas a llegar a ser más de lo
que ya eres
y la verdad lo decía el maestro shifu en
kung fu panda' 3 pero cuánta razón tenía
si fu la verdad si fu tenía mucha razón
si no haces más de lo que ya sabes hacer
no vas a llegar a ser más de lo que ya
eres tienes que conocer conocer y
conocer conocimientos nuevos
conocimientos aprender más y más cada
día no te permitas por un segundo
quedarte estancado porque el momento va
a llegar va a llegar y tú tienes que
estar preparado y cuando llegue el
momento lo vas a capitalizar cómo lo
vamos a capitalizar de la siguiente
manera trabajo
antes de pasar al trabajo les quiero
hablar del deseo el deseo es bueno pero
el deseo te sirve como una fuente de
motivación deseo sin trabajo y
conocimiento se quede en eso deseo nada
más el trabajo muchos de nosotros
decimos que queremos ser exitosos pero
que tanto queremos ser exitosos queremos
ser exitosos y como queremos sacrificar
y de fiesta
queremos ser exitosos así como queremos
sacrificar ir de sueño nuestras horas
tan prestigiadas de sueño
así queremos ser exitosos
y les voy a decir una cosa más trabaja y
trabaja y trabaja hasta que ya no puedas
más que tu cabeza esté lo
suficientemente cansada y tu cuerpo ya
no puede dar un paso más y en ese
momento
recuerdo porque empezaste en primer
lugar consejo número 3 y no está mal
escrito y no lo voy a decir mal ten
siempre miedo si ten siempre miedo el
miedo que es muchísimas cosas pero
dentro de nuestro cuerpo es una
sustancia y esta sustancia que se
desarrolla por todo nuestro cuerpo nos
va a decir una cosa y si la pudiéramos
entender nos diría el ojo hay peligro
ten mucho cuidado en ese momento nuestra
cabeza empieza a procesar distintos
escenarios posibles qué es lo que tengo
que hacer me tengo que quedar quieto
tengo que avanzar tengo que gritar o
chance no tengo que hablar entonces
nuestra cabeza está procesando la
información dijimos que somos
emprendedores no tenemos aquí atrás una
línea esa línea de este lado está todo
lo que dijimos esas metas esos sueños
esos deseos sostenemos de este lado y de
este otro tenemos el fallo y nuestra
cabeza nos dio la solución
sal de ahí
eso es lo que nos dice sal de ahí de que
voy a salir exactamente tenemos que
salir de ese fallo ese fallo es la línea
que nos va a llevar que aquí soy muy
bonita pero que está llena de obstáculos
que tu cabeza por el miedo te va a dar
la mejor respuesta que vas a poder tener
y no solamente te va a dar la mejor
respuesta te va a ayudar a hacer las
mejores respuesta de repente llegas aquí
volteas para allá
como le dice para llegar hasta aquí en
este segundo amigo mío
supiste tener miedo y cuando lo tienes
no existe el tiempo y el espacio es como
si separaran como si separaran y nada
más ves de frente a tu objetivo lo miras
bien a los ojos
y ahí tuviste miedo es distinto y es una
línea muy delgada entre tener miedo y
que el miedo que tenga a ti cuando el
miedo que tiene a ti las tienes las
piernas te tiemblan la garganta te deja
de funcionar la cabeza ya no tienes ni
un pensamiento en ese momento no lo
podemos permitir nunca el miedo puede
ser tu mejor amigo y debe ser tu mejor
amigo y nunca tu peor enemigo porque
puede ser puede ser que sólo tal vez tu
cabeza haga que sea tu peor enemigo
entonces si respeta quiere abrazar y
sobre todo te niego consejo número 4
conocen a esta persona de aquí atrás
esta persona de aquí atrás se llama
thomas alva edison
edison para los cuates entonces edison y
mucha gente lo conoce porque tiene
muchos inventos 1.093 patentes de
inventos para ser exactos y mucha gente
dice que su mejor invento es la bombilla
eléctrica que es lo que conocemos hoy
con un poquito más de arreglos pero lo
que conocemos hoy el foco otros tantos
dicen que es el fonógrafo y hay otros
que se atreven a decir que su mejor
invento es la cámara fotográfica porque
eso -dijo- dio pie a que el mundo
innovar y que aquel que digo yo que
ninguno está bien
el mejor regalo que thomas alva edison
le dejó a la humanidad es su capacidad
emocional para resolver los problemas en
el siglo 19 hay una constante búsqueda
por los conocimientos nuevos inventos y
ahí situamos a nuestro personaje a este
genio entonces él estaba empecinado con
una idea y su idea cuál era quiero
inventar el foco quiero innovar entonces
si se puso a pensar en esa idea cómo lo
voy a hacer qué es lo que tengo que
hacer y empezó una vez dos veces tres
mil veces lo intento y eso es mil veces
lo hizo mal
y la prensa llegó la prensa y le
preguntó un día un reportero edición
pero tú eres un fracasado a 50 dos mil
veces si lo has hecho mal
ríndete y él dijo amigo el que está
equivocado eres tú
ahora sé de qué mil maneras no lo tengo
que hacer para poder llegar a mi
objetivo ahora hace mil formas sobre las
cuales no puedo intentarlo para llegar a
mi objetivo 1880 edison patente el foco
y siguió hoy aquí aquí quiero llegar con
esto que el fracaso no existe el fracaso
nada más existe en el lugar más
maravilloso pero a la vez tenebroso del
planeta aquí arriba en tu cabeza
acuérdate cada vez que crees que
fallaste estás un paso más de llegar a
tu objetivo cada vez que digas que fue
un total fracaso mejor diste fue un
éxito porque ahora sé que no tengo que
hacer para llegar a mi objetivo y si no
me creen pregunten el
consejo número 5 y tu último consejo no
más negativos todos estamos
familiarizados con esto de aquí atrás no
juego de modo no tengo suerte porque a
mí y porque lo hacemos porque nos
decimos estas cosas olvídate de eso a
partir de hoy ya no van a existir los
negativos vamos a cambiar a cambiar toda
nuestra mentalidad y cuando te pase algo
ven el lado positivo que nadie te diga
que no existe el lado positivo porque
claro que existe de todo vas a sacar un
aprendizaje de todo vas a sacar cosas
nuevas entonces que nadie te diga que no
porque existe yo no quiero hacer una
pregunta porque reprochamos y gritamos y
nos enojamos cuando hacemos las cosas
mal o cuando creemos que fallamos y
porque nos festejamos como hacemos las
cosas bien es muy raro y yo todavía no
lo entiendo pero a partir de hoy vamos a
cambiar ese chip a partir de hoy si te
pasa algo como no querías que te pasara
si te pasa algo que crees que es un
fallo y no pasa nada vamos a la
siguiente y no pasa nada vamos a la
siguiente ya la siguiente ya la
siguiente en la siguiente hasta que me
salga pero si te llega a ir acorde al
plan a como tú querías
y acuérdate de estas palabras y ven los
fuertes que son oye
lo lograste
ahora
qué es lo que vamos a hacer número 1
vamos a ser reales que nadie te diga lo
que tienes que hacer tú sabes lo que
tienes que hacer tú lo sientes número 2
existe un gran camino corto y ese camino
corto se llama trabajo y conocimiento
nada más el deseo es extremadamente
bueno pero siempre mezclado con estos 3
número 3
en siempre miedo el miedo va a ser tu
mejor amigo no dejes que se convierta en
tu peor enemigo número 4
el fracaso no existe el fracaso no
existe no pasan cosas malas número 5
no más negativos las excusas así como
cualquier negativo son obstáculos que te
pones en tu cabeza que te van comiendo
por dentro después de estos cinco puntos
la pregunta importante es la siguiente
porque lo empezaría muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]